so
after all that
a happy ending
this video contains spoilers for better
call saul through season 6 episode 7 and
everything in the breaking bad universe
if you're not caught up this video won't
be for you
hey guys pete here the first half of
better call saul's final season is
complete and it went out with a bang a
literal bang as it were and with no
happy ending for howard who turned out
to be a guy who did not deserve what
happened to him it was a good way to end
an episode and the first half of a split
season though it left us with a lot to
consider and i'll be doing that over the
next couple of days with more videos but
i also wanted to touch on this
post-credits teaser they introduced
after the mid-season finale in a word
it's ominous but there's also a dash of
hope mixed in it's sparse but i found it
to be evocative for a couple of reasons
first it's a teaser in the purest sense
it doesn't show us any scenes from the
next episode or at least not in the
traditional way we're used to instead it
shows kim and jimmy's condo in black and
white there's nothing happening there
and the thing that stands out is that
it's much cleaner than when we saw it at
the end of episode 7. what i liked about
that ending is that the deed is done and
we're left speculating about what comes
next the teaser plays right into that
and where it gets interesting is the
small bit of dialogue jimmy or saul or
maybe even gene says
so after all that a happy ending what
really got me about this is that when i
tried to figure out when it might be
happening or the situation where he
might say this i realize that the
characters are kind of in a place where
i'm not sure what a happy ending might
be so that's the second thing how are we
supposed to be feeling about happy
endings and who deserves them in light
of what just happened i'll be getting
into all of that and i was thinking
today that after this ending i'll be
thinking about things a lot differently
when i go back and re-watch the first
seven episodes and if you're wanting to
do that but don't think you can today's
sponsor atlas vpn can help if you're
watching in the us you know that you can
only watch the first five seasons of bcs
on netflix in other parts of the world
like germany new episodes of season 6
are added weekly if you connect to a
german server through atlas vpn they'll
encrypt your data and give you a new ip
address so netflix thinks you're
connecting from germany reload your
browser and all six seasons are there
for the watching right now atlas vpn is
running a huge discount it means you can
get a three-year subscription for just
199 a month with a 30-day money-back
guarantee time is running out so get
your deal by clicking the link in the
video description below
i use a vpn for geo-restricted content
all the time since i live outside the us
even if you're not in my situation a vpn
is still a good idea because it makes
surfing the internet safer and more
secure with atlas you can enjoy blazing
speeds you can use unlimited devices on
this subscription stop ads and malware
and maybe even get better deals when
shopping online use the link in the
description below to get three years for
199 a month right now with a 30-day
money-back guarantee protect yourself
online and get access to geo-restricted
streaming libraries right now
so in this teaser we're looking at the
scene of the crime and beyond the lack
of color it's the lifelessness of it
that stands out to me we spent so much
time here over the run of the show it's
where jimmy and kim's relationship
really happens the scenes they shared
here early on were the ones that made
you want to root for them it's where
they eat their take out and cuddle up to
watch classic movies together it's where
kim broke down listening to jimmy
stoically read chuck's letter after he
died where they laughed together about
her kevin waltel impersonation where she
made her first u-turn and proposed they
get married and where they plotted out
their plan to humiliate howard hamlin
seeing it empty but with everything
exactly the same makes you think about
all the things that have happened here
and just how close we are to the series
coming to an end the black and white
brings up the idea of gene and omaha who
we haven't seen yet this season and even
though it's not a surprise i do have to
mention the other short teaser they
released hints that his return is
imminent this juxtaposition of a
location from the bcs timeline in
jean-style black and white muddies the
water about when the happy endings line
takes place in the current timeline
they're in the middle of a volatile
situation that we know at least saul
survives things will likely get ugly
with this new association with lalo so
there could be a happy ending when
that's over the way jimmy's voice cracks
it makes me think that he's talking to
kim which could be another sign that
it's happening in the current timeline
after he gets over the fact that lalo is
still alive everything we know about him
says his main concern will be kim's
safety i feel like any ending that
includes that could feel like a happy
one for him even if it's one where
they're separated if that's what has to
happen of course that would be
devastating for him but story wise it
would also open the door for a reunion
after breaking bad we know the series
will end there the season 6 poster is
gene putting on a jacket that screams
saul goodman and that is the place where
something new and surprising could
happen what that might be brings us back
to the question of what would a happy
ending look like and maybe more
importantly what makes sense for these
characters after the unintended
consequences of their plan and their
previous decisions played a role in
howard's death you could debate the
levels of responsibility but one thing
you can't deny is that if they had left
him alone howard would never have ended
up dead in their living room and it does
come down to choices because they had
chances to walk away on some level jimmy
understands just how bad things can go
wrong with his schemes after what
happened to chuck after he tipped off
the insurance company that in his trip
through the desert were enough to make
him hesitant to go through with kim's
plan initially but not enough for him to
tell her no or even better put a stop to
it once everything was in motion he got
what looked like a way out with the
judge wearing a cast but there kim
doubled down and made that u-turn to
make sure they could pull it off i don't
bring this up as evidence of how you
should feel about these characters but
rather to highlight the tragic results
of their decisions that brings us back
to consequences which we know are
important in stories crafted in this
universe they're woven into the fabric
of both shows and after my most recent
re-watch of bcs in its entirety the one
area i believe it's more successful than
its predecessor is its ability to
develop complicated characters in
breaking bad you were definitely
supposed to root for walt in the
beginning and then when more of his
nature was revealed you had to rethink
your position one decision they made
that helped you arrive at the right
place was to show that he always had
those heisenberg tendencies even before
he was diagnosed with cancer that event
allowed him to embrace the worst parts
of himself and made it possible for him
to justify every awful thing he did as
time went on you were forced to confront
the reality that he was just a ghoul of
a human being
jimmy and kim still seem more
complicated and part of what i love
about what bcs does is it puts you in
this place where you aren't sure how to
feel about them you know you were
supposed to root for them at times but
where exactly are we going in the
aftermath of the plan and the execution
it's all right to be somewhere on the
scale of hating them to still hoping
that they might turn it around howard
turned out to be a great example of this
and if you re-watch episode 7 closely
you'll notice how they very deliberately
showed you his flaws right beside the
reasons why you still should feel bad
for him anyway it's our nature to pick
sides based on what makes the most sense
from our experience but we understand
that real people are complicated in this
same way and assessing their worth or
what they deserve is never simple
because howard died and before he went
out he laid out a lot of really true
things about them it's difficult to
square what the consequences for this
should be and that's where we come back
around to the teaser would it make sense
for either kim or jimmy to have a happy
ending and then what would that be i
always thought kim would live because
there had been a lot of potential in a
reunion in the gene timeline after
howard's death in the revelations about
how doing things like this is what
drives a lot of their passion it doesn't
feel like having them come back together
in the end would hit the same way if
they can't help themselves and their
relationship would always become this is
there anything happy about it continuing
i guess the better question is
is there a path to redemption because i
do feel like there should be
consequences it doesn't seem like it
would feel like a gilligan verse story
if there weren't i think there's a
higher chance of it having an effect on
kim and what she does next but feel less
solid about that than i used to in the
aftermath i expect jimmy to go into
cockroach mode to ensure survival while
focusing on keeping his wife safe and
then if the past is any indication he'll
compartmentalize push down those
uncomfortable emotions and then likely
cover them up by fully embracing the
salt goodman persona we know what part
of his future is and being saul full
time separated from kim is a type of
consequence that leads to him becoming
gene both of those bits of his future
are devoid of what made him likeable as
jimmy mcgill and so in a way they are
punishment and it's not just
circumstance and things happening to him
he brought a lot of this on himself
kim is more of a mystery and it's really
hard to say where she goes from here i'd
like to hope that there's a path for
redemption but it's pretty difficult to
see from where we are as far as the
happy ending that's referenced in the
teaser if i had to pick something i'd
say it's of jimmy saying goodbye to kim
and the happy ending being they got out
of the lalo situation alive but i still
want to think that it could be from the
gene timeline and that the last six
episodes make whatever he's talking
about makes sense i can't wait to see
what they have planned and i think
that's a good place to leave things i'd
love to hear where you find yourself in
relation to happy endings and this
complicated group of characters we have
a six week break to kick it around and
i've got more related videos planned to
keep the conversation going let me know
what you think in the comments and what
you're thinking about after the
mid-season finale please like this video
if you enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon